do I look unhealthy take a look at this
physique I'm in phenomenal shape in body
and mind people say a loss can make a
break a fighter but trust me a win can
also make a break a fire if you can see
it here and you have the collision of
the sweetie it will happen nobody works
harder than me inside the Octagon
outside the Octagon I am a workhorse I
knew what was gonna happen I know what's
gonna get here
they didn't there's a lot of stressful
years a lot of tough times every gym had
a set way of doing things don't do it
this way do it that way
I always felt grateful for even the
small things I always used to celebrate
the small things and I slipped a punch
nice and I shuffled my shoulders I said
Muhammad Ali and true a shot people set
like goals long distance goals and [ __ ]
that's too much for me I appreciate the
support of all the fans out here and all
over the world I never take it for
granted I use it as motivation so he's
an Irish mixed martial artist he
competes in the featherweight and
lightweight divisions of the UFC he's
the current UFC featherweight champion
he's kind of a Gregor and here are his
top 10 rules for success what makes you
such a good fighter I am I don't know
I'm just curious about it I'm curious
about it it's never I mean it's in my
head 24/7 there's nothing else I can
think I don't I don't think about
nothing else if that's it I'm just
curious
curiously fascinated Lee and I can't
stop thinking about everything I do in
my life is is related to this I don't do
nothing else if it's not got to do it
fine I mean and that that is why and I
meant it to be true started early all
you've got to do is show up is that kind
of unhealthy and I don't know
do I look unhealthy take a look at this
physique I'm in phenomenal shape in body
and mind to me what's unhealthy is
living and on a healthy life to me
what's unhealthy is getting up and going
through the same day every day I like
9:00 to 5:00 in an office or in a you
know that bats unhealthy that beats your
mind I don't I don't work I do I love
what I do
and that's why I'm doing what I love and
I mean that's why that's why it's become
a career
me because I love it I love what I do so
I don't think it's unhealthy I uh I feel
good in my mind I mean it's it's my it's
my life chances well McGregor really
growing the legs to the side landing a
nice big shot china hutch Johnson with
some shoulders covering at the moment I
was love lovely left knee to the ready
sitting in that sideways position but
now just hitting the head and landing
big strikes as part of a Gregor the
answers gonna have to do something here
and that's it now always called a halt
to this Jetson was not intelligently
defending himself and Conor McGregor
wins
reaction from the crowd you stare at
your past and you'll end up staying
there it's okay to look back and admire
it but you carry on I'm not I'm not in
the business of staring staring back at
it you know I mean I'm getting lost back
there it's people say you can people say
a loss can make a break a fighter but
trust me a win can also make a break a
fighter because they get comfortable
with it with a win people can get
comfortable with it with a win and and
and slack off their slack off on the
train and slack off on the diet they've
won more they're winners now that's not
me you know you sleep on a you sleep on
a win and you'll wake up with a loss so
I just carry on keep doing what I'm
doing and that's why these turnaround is
so good for me they get straightaway the
Fighting Irish head to the fighting
capital it's it's perfect continue on
this path the freight train straight to
the top
if you can see it here and you have the
courage enough to speak it it will
happen so I see these shots I see these
sequences I don't shy away from them a
lot of times people believe in certain
things but they keep to themselves they
don't put it out there you truly believe
in it if you become mobile with it
you're creating that law of attraction
will become reality and you he would
overextend
I knew I'd catch him so majestic Knight
strikes again
I'm enjoying the fruits of my hard work
nobody works harder than me inside the
Octagon outside the Octagon I am a
workhorse so I'm gonna enjoy the
benefits for this life I'm gonna get
myself a big mansion in Las Vegas I'm
gonna get the soft hop cars I'm gonna
bring my whole team out I'm gonna spoil
them and give them this life
big stakes - sighs whirring and every
single night each we're eating good
we're living good it's it's human nature
some people will sit and take positivity
from that they will look at that and
take inspiration and inspire it will
inspire them to go and push for that
orders will shell up and critique it and
be negative towards it but one thing is
sure those people will stay where they
are the people who take inspiration from
it will rise up and also one day
experience that like so this is this is
human nature some going way so go do it
away but I am I am enjoying my money my
heart and money that I that I have
dedicated my life to
did you ever have let's call it a normal
job Connor a nine-to-five mm-hmm yeah
because the oldest thing is the gains
were trade straightaway I was no
different
soon as I finished skill I was always
getting pestered what are you doing with
your life you known this day on that and
they didn't know what it was they didn't
know MMA wasn't known I just didn't know
it can make a career as far as they were
concerned in mind that I'm talking about
as far as they were concerned I'm just
getting into a cage and fighting some
other guy they didn't know nothing about
it
no one did really but I knew and I mean
I knew but there and then I got end up
getting a trade just to keep them quiet
zhuzi it had a lot of fights with me
dialogue like trade did you get I end up
getting a trade as a plumber and
literally open the back eyes and I were
up and we clock the Wicklow Mountains
and feeling like that but sight was one
of the biggest sites in Europe kill
Tiernan was right at that ski in place
huge and now it's just abandoned now
it's just deserted so I used to go up
there six o'clock folks photographing
Amano's on that m50 I just had to walk
to the end for about half an hour from
your house wait for some limited guide I
didn't even know he drove on the m4 and
I had to flag him down
nightmare yep two hours down on the m50
two hours back usually 14-hour days and
obviously I was the first year so I was
the I had to go and do everything like
to go to the shop I'd to go and get this
and get that so I always had trouble
down I was like this isn't for me this
is not for me how long did you last I
lasted 18 18 months stealing what was
talking I just so it wasn't wasn't alive
for me and I'd and then John said
because I was training with jhana as
well at the time and then John got on
tour chances there I have a show on the
show would like to fight honey and then
that was he I just packed it in didn't
show up weed I used to come in and punch
the head on me and like try and drag me
out of bed and I just wouldn't go and
I'm it hadn't Oprah for a good few years
when I'm overbill and and that was it I
just packed it in quit and then focused
on training and that's I knew I knew I
knew what was going to happen I know I
was going to get here they didn't
there's a lot of stressful years you
know a lot of tough times and but I
proved them wrong I proved myself right
you say Jane Paul
since Steve oh Jesus he was out
he's just come back
every gym I went to I was always they
had a set way every gym had a set way of
doing things don't do it this way do it
that way so that was just a normal thing
that I talked I thought just people just
have their own set way and you must do
it that way you must stand this way you
must kick this way you must punch this
way but with John when I went to John I
met my coach John cabinet a straight
black team it wasn't like that he had a
more open mind and he encouraged
different movements and I never
experienced that before I've never heard
a coach say that to me before
and that stuck in my head and I thought
to myself you know this guy is thinking
outside the box and I mean that he has a
vision that everything walks on and he
encourages every movement because
ultimately there is a time and a place
for every single move so I just hot
I just near one when I met John and I
when he spoke it made complete sense to
me and that was the I stuck with him and
he stuck with me and the rest is history
I see
and whilst attitude is one of the most
strongest forms of power and attracting
good things you know if you truly feel
grateful for the things in your life
I always felt grateful for even the
small things I always used to celebrate
the small things now I might be
celebrating the bigger things but I
always celebrate every little good thing
that would happen to me in my life even
before I had any kind of money or any
that I would celebrate and I would feel
grateful for it and it just gave me more
and this is exactly the same thing
that's happening right now I still
remain grateful and more Combes
made it look easy
he said
I
of course I'm familiar with mama dolly
you don't just have him here he is
global he is he is the man
Muhammad Ali was a guy that don't what
had not been done before changed the
face not not only the face of his game
but the face of the world you know he
was a he was outspoken he fought he
fought for what he believed in and that
he was charismatic he he he was a legend
a hero and I looked up to him one of my
first heroes was Muhammad Ali uh when I
was 11 years old there was a group of
people and they tried to attack me and a
fight broke out and it was just me and
one guy before before everyone else
jumped in on me but we were fighting
each other and I slipped a punch and ice
and I shuffled my shoulders I said
Muhammad Ali and true a shot and he
rolled under the shop I fell into a knee
and I ended up on top of him so I'm at
the column I said Muhammad Ali and I'm
punching him in the head and then
somebody came in and tried to kick me
and then a whole group of them came in
and we it was just a big fight but it
was me against six of them and I ended
up getting my ass whupped but for that
first guy you you work them out and I
sure I don't know Ali shuffle I'm only
11 years old I don't the Ali shuffle
threw a left hook he rolled onto the
left hook with you if it was good of him
the road he saw her coming and rolled on
her but he rolled right into a knee yeah
I was I was I was prepared
I was I was studying tape so ya know so
definitely Muhammad Ali was a hero of
mine Potter's 12 weeks 11
backwards
dragger another first round win
all drug threats of UFC take you
that is exactly why he's so I don't like
to think too far ahead
so you haven't told oh no I don't like
to fart I had people set like goals long
distance goals and [ __ ] that's too much
for me I already feel like I'm living it
and then I just carry on the old I you
know carry on day by day already living
the final goal the goal of being the
world champion I already carry myself
like on my world champ and I already
speak like I'm a world champion and
that's it I just carry on day by day so
I'll take it as a corpse a lot again
like I said you were awesome ask me
about the future I let you I let you
know a little bit closer and remain as
far all I can see right now is the cold
that's all I can see is so very well
executed cheering oh boy because you're
having a home
oh wow
what
Carla trepidation coming in rather
okay Shira boost like most photos I
usually come out maybe three weeks
before but every time I come back it
seems to be a little bit more crazy with
the fans you know they treat me like I'm
one of their own and then I've been
driving to the gym everyday and I Drive
past this guy's apartment and it's like
on the balcony has like Irish flags and
cardboard cutout of me like sitting on
his balcony so now we're gonna go drop
into and see what he's about you meet
one of the finds good mr. Boudreau
what's up man how are you good how are
you
way but it's my I drove by a couple of
times as I thought oh yeah all the same
things I force my knowledge spit up
since your mom max all the way five yeah
I know and I look forward to fight next
week oh yeah absolutely yes you kidding
me I got my shirt my wardrobe in there
right I got your shoes you see them
right through there at the Reeboks yeah
I don't even have damn they are
unbelievable I'm telling ya honestly my
that's unbelievable gonna put on a show
for you but thank you so much yeah every
Saturday before the fight I put up my
cardboard cutout I put up the flag I put
up the banner the only thing I can say
and I hope Connor sees this is that that
feeling he had with Jose Aldo when he
knocked him out and he became the champ
hands down that's what I felt like
tonight like that's how amazing it was
and I really hope he sees that and I I
mean I think he saw it on my face and
there we go again see it's going again
but that's what that's the best I can
say men and I'm in a morgue right now
man I'm shaking I'm acting like such a
baby
I appreciated my relatives and others I
appreciate the support of all the fans
out here and all over the world I never
take it for granted I use it as a
motivation so I'm extremely grateful to
the fine
you
Oh
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because mr. 13 for Taylor
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave with the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I also love to
know which of Connors top 10 rules meant
the most to you is gonna have the
biggest impact on your life or your
business leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe I don't see you soon
there's parents coming in with their
kids from like the height bringing them
into the gym Amanda but I saw it
encouraging as never like that that's
going to go to a next level when you
have the parents encouraging the dream
and regardless of people again people
can say it's barbaric and martial arts
is barbaric
or this game is too it's too much be
anonymous two men beating each other or
whatever the martial arts life will give
you a discipline will give you
dedication will give you a drive that
you won't get nowhere else so whatever
these kids that come in that size with
our parents whatever they decide to do
where they decide to conquer the martial
arts world the fighting game or whether
they want to go and conquer the business
world whatever they decide to do
training for combat sport training
martial arts will give them that
confidence to go and excel and anything
so people can can criticize a better all
they want but the results speak for
themselves and seeing these little kids
come in this size it's good times good
times ahead
I see